hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry today
we're going to Jerry right we got
married recently
doom official gameplay trailer just
released III 2015 premature Rio whoa
Renee always possessive yeah
for real no yeah they were oh it took
over like below damn it's a badass song
whoa [ __ ] do
mmm this game looks [ __ ] awesome beef
I love it it sort of feels like halo
meets do well I mean is the first person
shooter thing which that I haven't
played doom in years but that is a
returning characters or not I've put it
in so long
yeah I think so but I do expert either
play the old-school one where it was
like just your hands or whatever when
all those games kind of looked alike
yeah
when like Wolfenstein and doom in all
those games kinda had the same template
so I call doom Ford and even though it's
technically the fourth doom game it's
just called doom again and it was taken
are you nodding in the middle my model
yeah it's like a part four but slash
reboot cuz there's like when they called
the thing the thing even though it was
the thing the beginning or whatever yeah
yeah but doom three we came out quite a
while ago yeah man it's been like
[ __ ] 11 years or some [ __ ] and I
think this is a game trailer so it's
probably coming out next year that's
what it said at the end did it it said
spring I was so caught up in like is
that a character spring 2016 yeah so
it's gonna be like what like 12 years
since the last one is gonna be 12 years
till it comes out from well beer so the
codes up for that I mean this game just
looks angry and mean and rad it's cool
because it has that classic type of doom
vibe it's weird like it doesn't feel so
chaotic as much I don't know I feel like
doom has always had you've got your
hands your guns and monsters and what no
what I mean is like it's it's
first-person shooter and people are like
I get it I'm probably people are gonna
be like this looks like Halo now but
what's cool is that the deaths though
this feels like an r-rated gory like
first-person shooter II game I mean I
feel like to say it looks like Halo is
kind of a narrow sighted thing because
at a certain point by that logic all
first person shooters kind of look alike
I mean it's like I can see my gun there
are monsters I have to shoot them and
get places and here's a
world it's kind of fantastical I know it
looks cool to me I mean like the deaths
look like a lot of they look like a
blast it doesn't have completely like
smooth motion you know kind of has that
like lagging motion that it had before
well anyway guys thanks for saying that
what's out if you're needed the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Jerry's place on this
channel reasons to Jerry his movie
reviews in this car he'd be like what's
up peeps movie reviews exactly like yeah
there's German you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
actually yeah and because if we can have
followers on any of these social
networks for vine example we can get
product placement so we could do vines
for things such as stress ball testicle
replacements nope testicle replacements
are great if you've ever done what I did
when I was young um I did not know what
testicles were so this is a true story
I used to I thought they were eggs
peppers up by my penis and I was like I
need to break these Dennis I used to
squeeze it as hard as I could hope we do
it just crack so Jessica replacements is
a serious thing people